thank you
[Music]
this story really
um it just surprised me because I didn't
even know that this could happen but you
know what you're looking at in this
picture
is that a side of a building are those
windows yeah
huh broken windows Yep it surprised you
but you didn't know which isn't throwing
rocks yeah Oh I thought they were like
that's the side of a cruise ship whoa
but do you know why this happened
Pelicans no it's just a wave no what the
wave brick Windows like a rogue wave
just hit the side of a cruise ship oh
wave got that high four people injured
one dead whoa wow how did they die it
doesn't say but definitely died a lot of
building on a cruise ship for a thing
like that that's what I'm saying like
who died I've heard a lot of crazy [ __ ]
on cruise ships I didn't know this was
one of them like you know what they say
when you jump out of like uh like a
helicopter or a ship or something and if
you hit water at a certain of height
it's like hitting concrete that's why
you gotta like enter a certain way if
the wave maybe comes at you like
completely flat somehow maybe it is like
a wall of concrete yeah you have to go
like this to pierce through the water
you have to open the window
how do you think that one death happened
because there's no info on it there's a
one death there's one death from this
before I was sleeping four injured one
death you know what's a weird maybe the
impact maybe they're like blunt for a
strong or something a weird experiment
I've always wanted to try it but I don't
think MythBusters ever did he's like
like you're saying like you're dropped
right from like a helicopter into water
if you drop a bowling ball first
and then it like blasts through the wake
is that easier for you oh I don't know
like it creates a little opening first
before you go in
I would assume yes
to be like really thinking about physics
if it's like there's no wind and the
water is just still and flat yeah and
you land on the flat I'm imagining that
to be the most painful thing but I
imagine if there's like waves or breaks
in it then there's more chances of you
not hitting one solid surface somebody
who knows something about more than just
dancing just to comment on this little
bit do you ever spend any time in the
Sun and outside of your [ __ ] crypto
office that to know anything about
nature I am darker than you I'm darker
than you actually we should compare all
right let's come over here is Steve
darker than me I don't know I can't tell
you uh JK we're gonna find out who
but like by a little bit
I think I'm probably a darker red I'm
the darkest yeah
throw your hands put your hands up Joe
Joe get closer to them I'm the darkest
who's darker uh actually Joe does I am
Joe's not in the competition I got a
good tab John stop trying to get his
[ __ ] you're not a joke I think Anthony
is dark yeah
all right edit that out
one boy sit down hey Jordan hats right
here all right I got my Joe Biden I know
I upgraded you upgraded damn I'm loving
this inflation right now
um I'm darker than everybody here have
you guys all been on a cruise yeah yeah
we did a JK Cruise you did yep and then
I vowed that never go ever again really
why your employees and spend money on
them you didn't like the cruise Bart
um I just don't think I like the whole
like sea legs aspect of it but it was
fun because of the group yeah but like
like going to sleep like this
and then all of a sudden like your feet
just go above your head and then you
stay there for eight hours how's that
happen I don't know I think because the
way they laid the bed maybe there's like
it was just Rocky only one way maybe
your legs just stayed in the airplane
decline I was like
oh this is weird
meanwhile there's giant arrows that are
like put head over here
maybe and then you would go outside like
could be you you open the window and you
could actually go into like the little
balcony area that was cool but then
sometimes it's like
she's like you're like oh [ __ ] you feel
like like fishing for [ __ ] crabs and
[ __ ] like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] close
that door you're gonna do karaoke what's
the most fun thing you did on the cruise
the when I got the stone massages and
then because the cruise ship was rocking
the stones were sliding off that was my
favorite
and then you would hear like the
masseuse try to keep it like peaceful
yeah you could maintain the Zen yeah
she's like yeah and just like put it
back on sounds Charming mine was going
to Santa Barbara oh yes
and thinking that we're stopping in
Mexico
because I was like oh we're going to
Santa Barbara Mexico oh you thought it
was showing up and I'm like this is a
California
pretty disappointed this is a cat at
least you're in charge of a news channel
yeah it's good it's very true but it's a
Spanish word Santa Barbara Anthony did
you enjoy your cruise uh I wasn't my
parents so no but they have a teen room
didn't they
uh it was uh I think if I were to go
back and as a as an adult because I
haven't been back to a cruise when I was
like post 21 without my parents I I'm
sure I could find my my version of like
fun that would be way different for what
I had back then but I can't speak on it
because I think when you're with your
parents like the level of restriction
and the level of things you don't even
want to get yourself into is so what age
what age was this oh it's probably like
17. oh okay where you did have a 24-hour
pizza bar which is pretty cool that was
really cool and you get ice cream you
didn't meet any girls
oh see that's good then the princess is
better I've heard that's good and
they're watching the little kid drown
was the best too
um
there's a swimming pool like in the
center of the front deck and then uh I
guess the parents let the grandpa watch
the little kid in the pool
and then so there's just them too and
then I guess we're getting over to like
pretty Rocky waves so now the ship would
like go forward so you'd see all the
pool water that could come and like
smash this kid and so the kid is like
pinned against the back of the pool with
all this water coming and then the
Grandpa wants to help but the grandpa is
just getting lifted into the air like
this oh my God so he's like here's I'm
gonna come help you but then the ship
would rock the other way so that all the
water goes like this so now the Grandpa
gets slammed back and then the water was
coming over here and now the kid is like
elevated like this and it was just so
funny because it was helpless like no
one could do anything I [ __ ] up Willy
Wonka [ __ ] see all this one like you
literally see a tray of water get half
empty and it's dry right here like if
there was [ __ ] sand dollars they
would have been exposed to the [ __ ]
Sun [ __ ]
it was pretty cool I've never kept
getting hit by 70 000 gallons of water
I've never seen Parts just like that
I've never seen a [ __ ] pool like this
before my whole life that's a true
that's pretty cool while I'm eating my
24 hours of pizza can they at least call
the wave pool at least change the sign
no I think it was meant to be true on
the ship right yeah because it was
rocking what's a rogue wave
that's a good question I don't think any
wave is non-rogue or is it because it's
Rogue because waves generally go a
certain pattern and sometimes maybe
there's just a random T-Bone one like
what's he doing there yeah why is this
one going this direction yeah I think
it's that I don't [ __ ] remember I
remember reading about this because I
was doing show prep the other night for
this but I think it's like a rogue wave
is like a random wave that's like a
different size like way bigger than like
the rest of the waves have been yeah and
then it just caught them off guard oh
[ __ ] yeah like it's like all the ways
were like this it's like this one just
came in like that all the waves are
crazy oh yeah it's a scientific thing
it's unusually large unpredictable and
suddenly appearing it just pops out of
nothing it's not in line with the
forecast I'm surprised this doesn't
happen more often actually it probably
does but you know the amount of them
that hits things I think if it happened
often it wouldn't be Rogue but that's
what I mean like for it to damage
unpredictable for it's a damage uh like
the wind yeah that's I mean I guess
that's the one in a million right there
like oh there's a rogue wave and it just
so happened that it has nothing to do
with weather right it's like usually
forecasting oh [ __ ] the ways will all be
rough here I feel like that's just the
cruise liner's fault it could yeah maybe
you know what I mean it's like you're
bringing people onto your ship into the
ocean it's like I'm at the end of the
day going to trust that this thing
operates on the ocean and if I'm
sleeping in my cabin and a wave comes in
and kills me like of all the places for
me to assume Danger on the cruise ship
this is why you don't pay extra to get
the room with the window you get the
whole yeah you like the porthole one
nothing dude the poor people are like
yeah thank God that's when I went on a
cruise Lucky Duck we got we got a free
cruise for my Dad's friend or something
and we were in the room with no window
was it really dark in there yeah it was
but we didn't have any threats of any
rogue waves or like the bottom floor
ones that are always underwater yeah
if you're in the bottom floor and you're
already under sea level then you never
get hit by a wave right yeah no but then
when the when it starts sinking you get
flooded first that's true that's true
yeah oh so if everybody's gonna die
anyway yeah then God dude that's when
you know what you're really poor is you
have the you know don't even get a room
you just buy a bunk bed space Oh and
then it's like a hostel
yeah that's the cruise ships Broiler
room yeah it's at uh Leo DiCaprio on
them did or whatever right after you
could Reuben like random poker games
it's like a hostile twenty dollars this
is gonna sound like another typical
[ __ ] story for me but I had a friend
who died on a cruise ship
that's not funny I've already done
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]